okay this one is for you this is of you
kemi from Mafia tush
um in Sancho
my my opinion on it
is
you have an attack
and then that attack is countered and is
countered with you Cami it's not a your
term my turn
and at higher levels
the form ends if you can't counter
the other person's role okay so what we
call intensive training uh I'm trying to
shut down the other person's Kimmy
ability okay so to train to that level
you have to counter with you camping
it's not my turn your turn also towards
that end I think Sancho is way too long
um to to be anything other than a modern
attachment to wanting to know forms like
you just want oh I I got a good note the
36 Joe all that's okay it's
gonna take you away from the finding
Spirit uh to have these long sets it's
because they're long you see people
getting very sloppy with their attacks
and their counters so when you practice
Sideshow as you see what we do we tend
to do one part only and it's already
long okay
not the whole three parts that make up
uh Sancho one or two what have you okay
so a drill to work on the ukemi
is you can uh you'll be doing the uh
technique
okay so I'll come around
uh here so your drill is here and uh
just so you can see what happens
his energy on being
his energy is going to roll around he's
gonna rotate around the cross
and it's coming down and I'm gonna
rotate around the cross again and
connect
so you again
this rotating cross pattern is Central
to aikido uh including internally uh
what it basically does is it captures
um
all the
vectoral manifestations of infinite
potentiality okay
um so you always are have a yin and yang
line and you're going to rotate them
around and in the rotation of them
you're manifesting the uh
the reconciliation of them so you have
it here externally in the form so I have
a uh one of the yin or young aspects he
has one of the yin or young aspects so
right now I'm currently young he's going
to go around it
and this is going to change the value
okay now he's going to be young and I
have subsequently become Yin go ahead
boom and there's the attack on the hand
okay side note here remember this timing
is embryonic so this is not the way you
do macchiatoos for real this is training
okay so in this training embryonic
version we can see my stock would come
around that would be young
he's going to rotate the cross he is now
young and I subsequently became Yin and
there would be the attack
and I'm going to do it back to him so he
rotates around
and I'm going to rotate around here and
then stick with him
[Applause]
[Music]
down in my hand
foreign
[Music]
okay what is key is that I don't
get positionally checked
and the way you don't get positionally
checked
is twofold
one
uh I don't want to have my hand hit
boom here okay that's gonna check me out
and two as he goes down through to my
center it's going to yank my
shoulders down you don't take it in your
shoulder because your feet will get
stuck and when the ski comes boom you're
gonna get ski
so as you reconcile it
it doesn't go
into your shoulders
you're going to keep your center from
being attacked by him by dropping your
Center
here
oh clicker do it
[Music]
different
okay and in my shoulders so I absorb
always in my income
[Music]
go now I'm gone
because I'm still mobile
so your Center has to drop as well as
rotating the cross
[Music]
okay
all right let's try